[Musique]
non
céline dion qui très las vegas après
avoir marqué profondément cette ville et
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'elle a
annoncé son départ et crémants qu'elle
pense à sa dernière série de spectacles
avec des sentiments mitigés et aussi que
las vegas est devenue sa maison en effet
au cours des 15 dernières années la
chanteuse a donné la majorité des
spectacles au caesars palace les ses
débuts le public est tombé sous le
charme
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup grâce à céline dion si
las vegas se porte bien aujourd'hui
l'arrivée de la chanteuse à relancer le
tourisme
son spectacle à générer 750 millions de
dollars en retombées économiques de mars
2003 à décembre 2007
céline dion a donné à las vegas 717
concert attirant 3 millions de
spectateurs une pause de quatre ans de
sa résidence en raison d'une tournée
internationale et de la maladie de rené
angélil puis elle renoue avec las vegas
2 mars 2011 à aujourd'hui et la donne et
372 concert devant un million et demi de
spectateurs janvier 2016 son époux meurt
quelques semaines après son décès céline
dion a célébré son millième spectacle à
las vegas
[Applaudissements]
son dernier concert au 6e para las aura
lieu le 8 juin prochain
en attendant céline dion prépare un
nouvel album ici andré daneau radio
canada montréal
tu as
détruits